hey was like guys my name is a Chennai
welcome to episode 67 of game
programming so last time we took a look
at basically you know creating our mouse
object and being able to detect mouse
position so we you know as you can see
this white square is following our mouse
pointer and also which button we press
since like that which was freaking
awesome so today we're gonna expand on
that because again the reason for even
adding the mouse apart from I guess
clicking on menus in the future and
inventory and everything is because
basically since since we're making em
since we're basically making roam on the
mad God we want to be able to send a
projectile or shoot in the direction of
where I Mouse's so if we click over here
we want to projectile to fly like this
right look over here we wanted to fly
like that etc okay so basically today
we're gonna start making that projectile
and being able to shoot things in
various directions which should be a lot
of fun so get excited okay
so let's close everything this is I just
like being organized and I like clutter
so puzzle and we'll only do stuff that
we need um and in fact I'm gonna show
you guys and I literally just thought of
this on the squad but it's probably a
good idea because this is this task list
is sitting here I'm gonna show you guys
how to basically um manage I guess your
tasks a bit better in Eclipse so this is
I guess this is eclipse only but
basically because what we want to do
right now is create shooting it's really
easy to kind of get sidetracked and not
really focus and maybe forget our goals
in the beginning and there's nothing
there's nothing worse than spending like
a few hours making something and then
going back and being like oh hang on a
minute I didn't make it to the
specification that I want to and it's
not gonna work this way that I've made
it now because I forgot of one little
thing so now I have to go back and redo
the entire thing from scratch yeah
that's not good so let's make a new task
so over here in Eclipse we've got this
thing called a task list very very
useful so if you don't see if some
reason where you've closed it if you get
a window show view task list all right
it's right over here if it's still not
here for some weird reason
hit other and just type in like task
list and it'll be right here okay
hey Council okay so let's add a new task
so over here in task list we've got this
new task button okay we can add that so
if you've actually got a repository
connected up to your like github or
whatever I'm not going to do that so
just local so in other words you don't
need to set everything up just hit local
it should be local butter fault and hit
finish that's it okay and it comes up
with this new task thing which is
awesome and there's attributes things so
that you can categorize and everything
will do that in a minute okay so this is
awesome and we've also got this context
thing which I'll show you guys in a
minute that's the that's the powerful
thing here so we wanna make a new task
right and let's call a player shooting
okay you can call it whatever you want
to say and status of his incomplete and
we can actually see all these other
statistics and we can see like how long
it takes us to do this this is really
really useful if you're working in teams
or really by yourself but what I mean is
it's even more useful if you're working
on in terms but anyway so basically our
goals for this is to make the player
shoot in the direction of the mouse
right and we want to I guess you know
shoot a projectile okay
that's sort of what what I'm doing as if
that's is so correctly spelled all the
time now that is pretty pretty sure
that's how you spell projectile and
there's a Google leather yep that is how
you spell projectile again that's one
clips but again we can also add things
like categories so you can see here
we've got um and on categorize one we
can actually add a new category here and
we can call it like play a game play for
example alright and then we can actually
pop this will actually have to save it
and close it and everyone again but we
can now pop this into play game play
alright and if we said that in player
and play now solutely can group all of
our things but what I want to show you
guys in what I like really like using
here is this context in context is
awesome because what you can actually do
here is you can actually add classes
that you will use for this okay so
basically you can think what do we need
to make the play out you know able to
shoot well we need the play class so
let's just add this in context in
Eclipse like I'm actually sure the
correct way to do it to be
quite honest but this is the way that I
sort of do it if you hit up player
shooting you see that we've got zero
elements at the moment in our context
what we can do though is we can hit this
activate button I can actually click it
up here and you can see that we've now
got kind of an empty contacts right so
otherwise what contacts does is it only
shows us the classes that you know are
actually part of this task so if we
wanna click here we can actually go down
to let's just say player which is here
right and I believe if you go to context
and show all of it and that's not it
okay if you hit the focus on active
tasks thing this is really I don't even
know what the right what it is is you
could say that we actually get elements
to that if you but what we can do is we
can click on player video and we can
actually yeah it like you know matically
gets added so again this is kind of
flawed but you can see that if we do
this now if I think I'll play here so we
can add the clauses that we think will
be necessary so I think mob might be as
well just because we want all the
players to shoot in the future as well
and let's say let's and well graphics is
screen as I ran a class right so that
would be eliminated because we actually
need to render the thing and I think the
other thing we'll need for shooting is
probably we're need input I think that's
it actually we can add more if we need
to but yeah so let's let's only shut the
contact now so this is really cool
because what we can do is let's say
we're working on something else here
we've got our game class open you know
it's all good let's actually get rid of
those get rid of that white square and
all that stuff so let's just comment
that out for now so that when we
actually launch our game we won't get
that white square thing okay sweet
awesome so now if we actually hit this
little activate button here then you can
see that everything else hides except
for the things that we need so we can
close this down so only more player in
screen is actually visible to us it
makes it really like kind of clean and
organized and just so that we don't get
to start with other things these are
really the only classes that we should
have to change obviously we can make
more classes as well but these are the
ones that we can change basically
without um that should affect shooting
so nothing else should be changed so
that's awesome so let's do that now okay
that was like a mini introduction
because I want I want you guys to sort
of be aware of how you know how it
should be done I guess in in a formal
way so over here in play oh the thing
that we really want to do here is we
want to shoot if something happens right
so if we go into mob I'm just thinking
about how I'm gonna do this what we want
to do basically is is in you know in
render sorry in update we want to
basically say that if
if we click right then initiate that
little shooting thing so basically what
we need to say is we can say is if shoot
or rather if Mouse stop what is it get
button right equals 1 which is the left
mouse button as you saw from last week's
video or yesterday's video actually
whenever we clicked the mouse button
equals one thing would pop up or
whatever
so if mouse button equals 1 then we want
to shoot right we want to shoot a
projectile now we want to shoot it as
specific coordinates and we kind of want
to shoot it at this point in time
probably where the mouse is right we're
gonna shoot it in the direction of where
the mouse is so we're in a few little
variables here or a few little um
parameters what we really want here is
the x and y of where the projectile
originates from so that will be the
player apps and player Y and again might
offset it to make it from the center but
we'll do that later synthetic or we also
want the direction so the direction we
will work out in a minute but that's
basically what we need right
so actually we got the direction that's
the player direction there so let's make
that method now but let's not make it in
the play class let's make it in the mob
class right because other mobs are gonna
be able to shoot as well not just the
player so Pub are protected avoid shoot
and again that will take all that
through parameters which is in X&Y and
probably a either a floor or a double
which is a double down for direction so
let's come back here into our player
class list with a new screen for now so
what we want to do now is basically
figure out well we've got X&Y already
done right so the only thing we really
need figure out is the direction and
what I might do here is let's come back
into update just to clean this off
there's a bunch of stuff here
shooting thing I don't want to call it
update shooting alright we'll just make
the quick method to up there shooting
just because I'm you know there's a
bunch of yourself gonna be here and I
just want to organize it a bit better
but this will basically run every loop
so if Mouse one equals one
right what we want to shoot at more I'll
shoot from these two points into into
this direction okay now the only thing
we already got X&Y right that's just the
player location we've got that that's
awesome but what we don't have right now
is the direction and we need to work
that out based on where the mouse is
right so this will involve some mouths
obviously you should have seen that
coming
let's think about it logically though
because you know that's nice little
awesome so we need a workout if you okay
if I just place my mouse pointer here
okay I have not done this in ages and
I'm not excited to do it again freakin
paint.net alright yeah I'm talking about
alright cool so if the player is right
over here yeah I should get a graphics
tell that it's like if the players right
over here and this is the player cuz
okay there and our mouse pointer this is
an ounce pointer by the way surprisingly
good-looking is over here right we want
to shoot in this direction correct
of course so what do we know what what
can we work out we we've got two
coordinates here right x and y and we've
got two coordinates of the actual player
right x and y this looks like crap but
whatever I might get a tablet honestly
right we've got these two points so now
what we can do is we basically just need
to figure out this angle and we've got
this point right because we we can
actually get this line by subtracting
this y-coordinate from this y-coordinate
and we can get this line by subtracting
this x-coordinate from this x-coordinate
right so we've got these two right and
what we need to do is figure out the
angle here
that's thither okay and we can do that
obviously since we've got the opposite
side and the adjacent side we can use
tan we can use the inverse tan tan -1 to
work out opposite over nopes not a bit
opposite over adjacent right and we know
that this again is why - I'll just call
that y2 - y1 and this is x2 minus x1 so
that's what that's what a equals and
that's what our equals okay so now we
can just plug it into this equation and
it'll be awesome now a few things you
need to know about this right there are
a few functions that we can use right so
10 minus 1 is obviously the same as
arctan or as its this is ridiculous
isn't it or as its called
you know in Java a 10 but there is
actually an a temp function and you
might notice there's also an ATM to
function now what's the difference well
the awesome thing about 2 which is the
one we'll be using is that there's no
way we can possibly divide by zero
because if we try and divide by zero so
was it gonna crash our program a crash
our game because we cannot divide by
zero now tanto basically just says if
you know if the thing we're trying to
divide by is zero then just return like
whatever don't crash the game so in
other words it actually handles that
just a tan does not handle it okay so
that's the basic maths of how we're
going to do this if again I was gonna
save this stuff for the in-depth series
but anyway this is just so you get a
basic you know I guess viewing angle of
how out roughly works okay so we're
gonna use this math now to figure out
the angle that we need so if you look at
it this way
what we need right now is we just need
to plug in two things into tan - right
opposite and adjacent sides so a equals
that which is just that the mouse
x-coordinate - do you play as
x-coordinate and opposite equals the Y
could the mouse is like one of mine it's
the player's y-coordinate okay so let's
look at that let's work those things out
right now so I'll call let's make DX
that one so it's kind of again it's
going to be Mouse not get X - and we
should really only do this if the mouse
button is pressed cuz there's no point
to do it it's not
- player X which is just X right one
thing we do have to do though is make
this absolute because you know obviously
if that if we shoot this way then the
mouse's thing - this is going to be a
negative number so we can just flip it
make it positive basically again an ABS
we'll just make sure that if it's zero
I mean if it's less than zero we'll just
make it it'll basically multiply by
negative one if it's negative okay so
double dy equals the same thing that's
not a BS it's Mouse get Y minus y again
so those are our two things to get out
now we just need flog them in which is
pretty simple now one thing you might
not know is that you actually have to
put in the Y first okay so so double
which is the direction equals math a 10
- okay so you probably just tells you
that everyone but yeah you can see that
over here in a town - we need to return
we need Y X right whereas here well we
said a but that's just the angle already
but in a time - we need the Y oh yeah
that's the other thing that a tanto does
by the way is really useful for gaming
because it actually separates a into two
different variables but um Y first and
then X right so math dot a town - dy/dx
but that's already there for us
brilliant and then we can send this
direction into this method and it will
hopefully you know produce a good result
so that is the basic maths of actually
determining the angle in which we need
to fire the projectile and then
obviously we'll have to use vectors to
actually animate the projectile flying
into that angle but let's just check out
what this looks like so over here and
shoot let's just print out you know the
angle because we don't really care about
external has
the thing that we did so you can see
here that as I move the mouse round and
I'm clicking obviously if you click and
drag it's not I don't think but if I
click you know it's getting all these
different awesome things and I just
realized what an idiot I am
we don't need ABS yeah because I don't
know why I was thinking we made that
let's get rid of ApS okay cool so now we
go negative and positive angles which is
good so yeah that is basically how it's
gonna work
yeah enjoy okay so I'm just worried
about why that's not positive should it
be I don't know anyway point is well I
guess we'll see when we actually 1.6 1.1
no I guess that works maybe not hmm
anyway well um I'm sure we'll look it
out when we actually put it into play
and I am pretty sure that's right anyway
oh yeah and of course we can't realized
we don't need ax here there's a decent
player acts we don't need that because
player X's we need the central we need
the actual players position on our
screen which never changes right he's
always in the middle of the screen
because remember we're getting there
Mouse pointers direction on the screen
not on the map right so be useless
getting the players direction on up
location on the map we want to actually
get the players location on our screen
which is pretty much in the center right
so let's just pretend it is exactly the
center because it pretty much is our
screen width I believe is 301 success
okay 301 6 at around of that so in one
is 300 wider by one subset oh sorry
what about 2 and this is 1 6 8 over
there all right so now if we do this
thing what we should get
is awesome so now we get the actual
angle what this seems to be zero okay
four point three point one yep zero and
that's what never change okay sweet so
there we go that's how we that's how we
actually get the angle so remember it is
the mouse location on screen - the
center because when I drew this thing
here the player you have to basically I
hope you guys realized my mistake that
you know we want to be able to actually
get the players location on our screen
right which is always in the center
since the camera follows him and it
won't actually always be in the center
because sometimes the player might be
offset for various reasons and we'll
talk about that in an upcoming video but
yeah basically you need to make sure
that you're getting it on the actual
screen since the mouse pointer locate
the mouse pointer coordinate that we're
getting is is just on the window not on
the map so obviously we need to get the
players location in our window not on
the mat so yeah anyway I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please hit
that like button and next time I see you
guys we'll probably talk about actually
creating that projectile and animating
it so yeah till then good bye
you